MARK MIRCHANDANI:
This week, we're
talking about task queues,
big data, and Stackdriver.
Welcome to This Week in
Cloud, where we serve you
the lowest-latency news.
Just recently
launched for everyone,
Cloud Tasks is a fully managed
service backed by App Engine.
You can easily create
new queues and offload
any asynchronous
tasks, giving you
a distributed task queue
that you can integrate
with any of your apps.
With built-in scheduling
and de-duplication,
as well as an
easy-to-integrate API,
Cloud Tasks can be a great way
to simplify your architecture
and focus on what matters--
the users using
your application.
Check out the details and get
started with a quick start
guide.
All you need is a GCP
project with App Engine.
You may already keep up to date
with news about Apache Hadoop
and Spark.
But Cloud Dataproc has lots
of new features to try out.
Dataproc is Google's
fully managed Hadoop
and Spark service
and has added tons
of integrations and
features to help
you build big-data solutions.
This includes support
for new versions
of software like
Ubuntu and Flink,
easy-to-add components, such
as Jupiter and Zeppelin,
and lots of Google Cloud
integrations, like BigQuery.
The full details are in
the blog post, as well as
some links for you to try
out Dataproc for yourself.
But no matter where
your app runs,
you'll likely need to
know how it's running.
Well, that's one thing
Stackdriver can help with.
Charles Baer, a Google
Cloud solution architect,
recently published
a blog post on how
to build your
application and monitor
for long-term metric
analysis, making it easier
to spot trends that you may not
see from reviewing short time
frames.
We've got the high-level
considerations
and an in-depth solution
guide with a reference
implementation, so you can
start to see the big picture.
And if you want to learn a bit
more about Stackdriver itself,
I definitely recommend checking
out the Stackdriver sandbox.
It's an open-source
set of tools that
make it easy to get started and
learn what Stackdriver can do.
You can clone the
repo and simply run
a script to set up a full
demo environment, including
a microservices-based demo
application and traffic
generator, giving you
the benefit of working
in a real scenario without
disrupting your production
environment.
This is a great way to
learn more and practice
how you might do some SRE
tasks in Google Cloud.
So don't delay, and try it out.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.